ja ich grüße sie sehr herzlich in dieser
neuen legislaturperiode
ich freue mich und wir freuen uns
darüber dass wir hier antreten mit einer
bundestagsfraktionen die so gross noch
nie gewesen ist bündnis 90 die grünen
werden hier in diesen deutschen
bundestag vertreten sein mit 118
personen mit 16 menschen die direkt
gewählt worden sind mit zwei trans
personen mit einer guten mischung aus
jung und alt aus ost west nord süd mit
und ohne migrationshintergrund
der altersdurchschnitt ist wie die frage
auf alles 42 wir freuen uns sehr darüber
dass diese vielen menschen jetzt
hochmotiviert hierhergekommen sind
natürlich jetzt nach ihrem platz im
parlament suchen werden aber vor allem
hoch motiviert sind dass das was wir in
diesem wahlkampf zum thema gemacht haben
nämlich den weg deutschlands in die
klimaneutralität und in eine gerechte
gesellschaft des zusammenhaltes jetzt
nicht nur parlamentarisch sondern
hoffentlich auch als regierungen
starterin
realität werden kann darauf freue ich
mich nicht nur sondern ich glaube dass
der aufbruch in diesem land der zu
spüren war auf vielen vielen plätzen in
den letzten monaten dass der aufbruch in
diesem land der notwendig ist weil das
was wir hier tun werden was wir
hoffentlich als regierungspartner in
thun werden das hat nichts damit zu tun
ob grüne ein besonderes ergebnis haben
ob es für die grünen in irgendeiner
weise wichtig ist sondern es geht darum
dass wir eine antwort geben müssen auf
die verhältnisse eine antwort geben
müssen auf die wirklichkeit die
wirklichkeit ist dass die klimakrise
drängt die wirklichkeit ist dass der
gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt in
unserem land nicht vollständig
hergestellt ist darauf antworten zu
geben dafür treten wir an dafür treten
wir entschlossen an und darauf freue ich
mich auch ganz persönlich
ja auch von meiner seite herzlich
willkommen
ich freue mich auch sehr dass wir eine
so große fraktion sind eine sehr
vielfältige fraktion von erfahrenen
gewerkschaftler innen bis zur ganze
reihe von klima aktivistinnen und mit
dieser großen fraktion wollen wir
dieses land in eine bessere zukunft
führen wenn man uns die vergangenheit
anschauen da gab es in den letzten 16
jahren sehr sehr viel reformstau werden
wir darauf schauen was wir in der korona
panini erlebt haben die digitalisierung
nicht funktioniert hat wie schwer es war
dass ämter zum teil ins arbeiten
gekommen sind das heißt wir haben
wirklich große aufgaben vor uns dafür
wollen wir eine regierung unter einer
regierungsbildung beteiligen die
regierung schafft die keine regierung
mehr des kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners
ist sondern eine regierung die gemeinsam
die lösungen findet sucht und findet die
auf augenhöhe mit den problemen sind wir
müssen die klimakrise nicht nur ziele
definieren sondern auch maßnahmen
ergreifen
das ganze wirklich umsetzen wir reden
seit jahren über unsere defizite bei der
digitalisierung über die funklöcher und
es ist viel zu wenig passiert wenn wir
uns anschauen unser staat muss
modernisiert werden wir müssen wirklich
einen modernen funktionierenden staat
bekommen wir müssen die
herausforderungen europas angehen und
dafür brauchen wir eine regierung und
wenn wir uns jetzt anschauen
wahlergebnis kann man ganz klar
konstatieren die spd hat stark zur
gewonnen die union hat stark verloren
und deshalb sozusagen wir werden
selbstverständlich mit allen
demokratischen parteien reden aber
ist es auch wahrscheinlicher dass es am
ende zu einer ampel kommt wenn es ganz
vorsichtig ausdrücken will wir werden
wie gesagt mit allen reden aber die spd
hat er schon bekanntgegeben einzuladen
und
wir werden es freuen uns auf die
gespräche wir freuen uns auf die
einladung und wir werden alles dafür tun
dass konstruktive gespräche gibt und
hier wirklich die probleme in diesem
land angeht nicht das ist was notwendig
ist das ist das was die bürgerinnen und
bürger erwarten
politikerinnen die sich drum kümmern
dass die probleme gelöst werden und als
allererstes wird es jetzt gespräche ist
ja schon angekündigt worden
unseren beiden spitzenkandidaten und von
der fdp gespräche zwischen fdp und uns
geben die spd hat schon eingeladen und
wir sind uns sicher dass wir zu
interessanten gesprächen kommen wir
haben wir freuen uns auf die gespräche
wir bereiten uns darauf vor wir sind
darauf vorbereitet und
das wird ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass wir mit dieser großen fraktionen
was gutes für unser land erreichen
können
geben soll das robert habeck den
vizekanzler posten bekommt naja es gibt
ja artikel dazu und es gibt die
wirklichkeit die wirklichkeit ist dass
die beiden spitzenkandidaten die beiden
parteivorsitzenden diese verhandlung
gemeinsam führen werden und die
wirklichkeit ist dass unter den beiden
alles besprochen ist und dass wir
personalentscheidungen am ende treffen
werden
neben es nichts hinzuzufügen wir werden
die personalentscheidung im gesamten am
ende treffen
[Musik]
bundestagsfraktion ist zentral ich werde
das so gelingt wie wir es vorhaben wird
es eine regierungsfraktion werden und
die regierungsfraktion muss die
regierung tragen und wir haben zwei
spitzenkandidaten und diese beiden
spitzenkandidaten führen jetzt die
verhandlungen und alle anderen fragen
personal unsere alter was sie da alles
fragen das wird am ende entschieden und
da können sie auch ganz häufig jetzt
noch fragen es wird trotzdem am ende
entschieden
die fraktionsspitze entschieden
zu den sondierungen noch einmal die
beiden können nicht alleine die
behandlung gibt es schon ein
sondierungsteam
also wir werden einen vorschlag machen
dazu in den nächsten wochen gehen
innerhalb der bundestagsfraktion
das wären wir nachher hier besprechen
mit den fraktion ehren und das zweite
ist ja es wird natürlich ein
sondierungsteam geben um die beiden
stars und die beiden parteivorsitzenden
herum und darüber wird der
bundesvorstand zeitnah entscheiden also
machen sich keine sorgen das
funktioniert alles gut und es ist auf
einem guten weg so dass wir jederzeit
gesprächs und verhandlungsfähig sind
[Musik]
der ort überall geben
in dem sinne in diesem artikel
es ist überhaupt nicht unsere aufgabe
personalspekulationen innerhalb der
union zu kommentieren aber der
kanzlerkandidat der union war herr
laschet habe ich gesagt es ist nicht
unsere aufgabe jetzt
personalspekulation in der union zu
kommentieren
die andere ist
ja interessant dass die union sich jetzt
erst mal damit beschäftigt welche welche
kandidaten sie irgendwie ins rennen
schicken wollen können sie gerne machen
dürfen sich unsere aufgabe ist auch
nicht unser thema unser thema ist dass
wir gut sortiert in die gespräche gehen
und ich habe dazu das gesagt was dazu zu
sagen ist nämlich die wirklichkeit ist
annalena baerbock und robert habeck
führen die gespräche auf augenhöhe und
am ende wird über das personal als
ganzes entschieden werden und dann
werden sie es erfahren wahrscheinlich
als einer der ersten herrscher
als einer der ich lege darauf wert dass
ich das so gesagt habe
doch erst die sonne raus kann schon sein
dass es dann mehr mehr leute sind noch
aber
erstmal der fdp wo liegen denn die
größten hürden zwischen ihren zwei
parteien
zwischen fdp und grünen gibt es
natürlich unterschiedliche auffassungen
was ordnungspolitik angeht auch aus
steuerpolitik angeht aber es gibt
natürlich auch gemeinsamkeiten aus
bürgerrechte angeht und entscheidend so
zu sagen ist dass man sich zusammensetzt
dass wir fest stellt man kann da was
gutes draus machen und dass man in
vertrauensvolle gespräche kommt und
gemeinsam sozusagen die probleme
beurteilt und dann lösungen für diese
probleme findet und da sind wir sehr
optimistisch dass das gelingt in der
opposition hat ja auch oft sehr gute
gespräche mit der fdp und bei ganze
reihe von punkten auch gute
zusammenarbeit über die gesamte
kritische opposition hinweg
ich
würde auch nichts anderes sagen das
entscheidende wird doch sein für eine
regierung in dieser zeit dass man sich
nicht an den unterschieden ist sondern
dass man sich überlegt was kann man aus
den verschiedenen ansätzen den problemen
dieser zeit zu begegnen eigentlich
gemeinsames ganzes und vielleicht auch
neues machen das wird das entscheidende
sein für uns nicht das irgendwie einen
das und die anderen das und die dritten
das und dann hat jeder seine spielwiese
nein im gegenteil
es geht um ein gemeinsames ganzes geht
um gemeinsam aufbruch ich glaube das
erwartet die gesellschaft auch das
erwarten auch die wählerinnen und wähler
stärker aufstellen könnte oder würde
dann alle sozusagen ihr eigenes völlig
in ihrer eigenen zunge noch weiter
durchzusetzen ich glaube dass es in
jedem fall ein auch gut ist wenn man
gespräche führt und das haben in den
letzten jahren gemacht das muss man auch
jetzt machen nach der wahl das geschieht
gerade und darüber freue ich mich freuen
wir uns klappt man kann auch ganz
nüchtern feststellen dass die zeit der
großen volksparteien vorbei ist und der
mensch der kanzler wird der ist von fast
75 prozent der wählerinnen und wähler
nicht gewählt und deshalb ist es auch
eine andere dynamik in seiner regierung
und deswegen ist auch klug wenn die
nicht ganz so großen partner in seiner
trauer konstellation miteinander
sprechen genau
danke danke